[Music]
being a superhero
is a trial by fire
who's gonna protect the world it's not
people like you
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm jennifer walters i'm a lawyer i have
great friends can we get some shots
please it's an emergency a demanding job
we just started a superhuman law
division and i want you to be the face
of it
and a frustrating family because we
didn't ask for this
but you still got to deal with it your
transformations are triggered by anger
and fear those are like the baseline of
any woman just existing
oh
rude i feel like if i don't transform
i'm gonna die
yes yes yes
no no
i just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer can you tell us where she-hulk is
jen you're a story now
girl your ass looks crazy right now
you could be an avenger oh i'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
[Music]
is there anything more depressing than
dating in your 30s yeah this is the best
that i've had in a while oh should we
split some fries let's get those to go
[Music]
you